this morning on our saturday session my
morning jacket the childhood friends
from louisville kentucky have been
making music together for decades and
nearly called it quits but then they
produced a new self-titled album and
reclaimed what rolling stone calls their
mantle as retro rock's top mystics
they'll perform new music in just a
minute but first here's anthony mason
excuse me
you know i
beg your pardon
for this interruption
now back to regularly scheduled
programming
when my morning jacket took a hiatus in
2017 they weren't sure they'd ever get
back together
so lead singer jim james and drummer
patrick hallahan had no expectations
when the band finally returned to the
studio
we weren't even going to make a record
like let's just get together yeah let's
hang out let's
heal you know like let's
just kind of get to know each other
again it just felt so nice that
eventually we started making a record
[Applause]
when you say we had to heal what were
you healing from you know i think
communication i think really like
there's
i think as i examine myself through
psychotherapy and other means i i
realize i've been a pretty bad
communicator in my life i mean our
friendship went through a rough patch
because of that yep
[Music]
the group which came out of louisville
kentucky back in the late 90s had been
on the road regularly ever since
did you think about calling it quits
oh yeah i've thought about calling quits
many times yeah there's never really
been any tension in the band but uh
touring really for me has been so brutal
over the years because before
we would say yes to everything and it
would just end up killing killing me
when he asked me to join the band it was
like the one thing that i said was the
minute that we feel like our friendship
is going to be
compromised by this thing then we're out
and because your friendship was more
important yes yeah and it
got beyond that and it that was the part
that really hit me harder than anything
so
getting right with him was super
important to me
your relationship is important because
you've been friends since when
the summer between
third and fourth grade
long time
[Laughter]
we realized one day that we lived right
down the street from one another yeah
then we found out we had the same
birthday
yeah and then there are just certain
little gifts that the universe
plants in your uh in your orbit
he's one of them for me
[Applause]
how did you feel about the music as it
started to come out
well it was cool because this round
you know a lot of other records there's
all this pressure you know you want to
blow everybody's mind and make make the
greatest record of all time you know the
pressure's on it's clock's running you
know studios 800 thousand dollars a day
you better make it good you know and
we're on there one two three four bang
bang bang yeah and you're like you know
it just gets so stressful but with their
new album my morning jacket returned to
what they'd first relied on
themselves our collective chemistry is
so special and that's one of the things
that really
really came to uh
all of our realization as we were
getting back together as gosh it
would be such a shame to
to lose this
[Music]
[Music]
foreign